Jin says I'm trying to have a better
sleep pattern people always say go to
bed at the same time every night but
they don't have to work early 6:00 a.m.
shifts like I do
yeah I'm still good advice though I mean
to go to bed at the same time I mean
even if she works at 6:00 a.m. what
she's got to get up at 4 a.m. or maybe
5:00 a.m. to get there at 6 a.m.
and yeah maybe you have to go to bed at
8 o'clock at night and that fine better
day but I'll tell you that's one of the
things that has helped me improve my
sleep is going to bed at the same time
every night I try to get in bed at 9:30
I usually fall asleep by 10:00 or 10:30
you can go to bed earlier my daughter
goes to bed around 7:00 and sometimes
I'll go to bed around 7:05 but I like to
get up early as why I get up early and
right and it's just it's about
preference now she's saying she has to
get up at 6:00 now there are couple
things you can do here
one is you can also change your job
ultimately if you're working a third
shift job for 20 years it's gonna take
years off of your life yes there's a lot
of studies about third shift I think for
this individual in particular the next
question would be what is your sleep
hygiene sleep hygiene is a a medically
relevant field and there's a couple
things that any individual can do that
they can take away from this discussion
one is temperature of your room right so
69 degrees if you can control it is you
know 69 70 degrees optimal temperature
make sure everything is very very dark
because you don't want outside light to
stimulate you know through your eyelids
like we were talking about those
melanopsin yeah blue light receptors why
you know receptors not just in your eyes
yeah I could all wear our face mask but
like you have it in your ears your skin
your room as dark as possible
white noise eliminating ambient noise
from the outside that will cause you to
cognitively become more alert whether
you realize it or not and shift you from
REM or deep sleep into more of a an
alert state that's another thing we
talked about the pattern and the to
using your bed only for sleep
essentially so you know if you have a
partner perhaps designating an area for
intimacy or if you are going to have
intimacy you know making sure that yeah
yeah did you know get creative with it
but you know the bed should be for sleep
it shouldn't be for work it shouldn't be
for anything else for TV either
no TV out of the back rack so creating a
space that's safe comfortable
temperature control there's the white
noise component eliminating like we
talked about those sources of EMF or
other thing and I suspect in addition to
that similar pattern of going to bed
around the same time every night and
getting up around the same time every
morning you will find wakefulness is
easier to achieve as well as a
satisfying and nourishing night's sleep
now the next person slow and simple
living has a similar question but it's
about insomnia so I know Beck's suffered
with insomnia so insomnia isn't the
inability to go to sleep or your waking
up a little night and staying or a
staying awake or does that have to do
with melatonin production or I mean I
think we use insomnia loosely right so
if someone actually has legitimate
insomnia but usually that would be like
a symptom of something else going yeah
you again a better evaluation with a
health practitioner to try and figure
out what is contributing to that
insomnia because there's multiple
reasons why few hundred yeah you know I
mean there may be a valid medical reason
that requires medicinal intervention but
I think for most people that lack of
ability to sleep contributes to societal
or lifestyle factors that cause stress
anxiety you know something both
physically or mentally that prohibits an
individual from achieving that affective
sleep you know the thing you think you
have you may not have you may not
actually have insomnia you have insomnia
symptoms because of the environment that
we are all yeah yeah so try try
eliminating blue light try drinking
coffee only you know before 10:00 a.m. I
mean there are a lot of little things
you can do I'll tell you one thing that
has helped me and I noticed is going
from like hot to cold like June whether
it's the sauna like those are the best
nights of sleep I get are the days or
are the nights after I go to the Russian
bathhouse because it's that going from
super hot to super cold and sometimes to
like if I'm having trouble sleeping you
know nights back-to-back like I will go
out of
way to get in the shower and do some hot
and then 30 seconds of cold 30 seconds
what people have to appreciate - I've
failed to mention with the night time
habits not eating within about 2 hours
before you go to bed yeah there's a
reason for that so sympathetically
fight-or-flight so a sympathetic nervous
system fight-or-flight parasympathetic
vagus nerve rest and digest
they're more commonly known now if you
are hot or if you have eaten a meal
within roughly 2 to 3 hours before you
go to bed your sympathetic nervous
system essentially revs up to help
control temperature there's a component
that it's coordinating digestion so your
core body temperature actually elevates
and then you're trying to sleep and your
body finds rest most effectively when
your core temperature is relatively
lower which is why temperature in the
room is important so you're effectively
fighting against yourself and it's
natural process if you're too hot or if
you've eaten too soon before you go to
bed which contributes to why you find a
benefit from taking a cold shower before
you go to bed because you're helping
your body get into a state that it can
achieve successful relaxation right
those are all things that are common and
I'm sure if this individual just goes
through those those simple steps and
says ok hey how am i doing a through e
they likely will find better rest and if
they do all those things and they do not
then perhaps a sleep study medical
evaluation there are sleep physicians
that this is literally all they do would
be a reasonable intervention but
starting with those simple lifestyle
modifications will most likely be
beneficial I'll tell you - like getting
something like the war ring or some kind
of sleep tracker that helps you identify
your good nights of sleep versus bad
nights of sleep like those little things
that you do you will find out with the
data that says yes I am getting better
sleep when I don't eat 2 hours before
bed or yes I'm getting even better sleep
when I do cold showers before I could
have been yeah obviously check out dr.
Walker's book why we sleep I think
that'll help point you in the right
direction
you